dans l'actualité du nouveau pour la
ligne 18 du métro où elle doit relier à
l'horizon 2030 pour rappel versailles à
l'aéroport d'orly dix gares seront
desservies dont à saint quentin est à
guyancourt elle le tronçon aérien on l'a
appris récemment va être quelque peu
retoqué environ 12 kilomètres étaient
prévus en viaduc sur le plateau de
saclay finalement face aux oppositions
locales et dans un souci d'économie la
société du grand paris a pris la
décision de construire une partie de ce
tronçon au sol entre saclay et magny les
hameaux ce qui enlèverait 5 des 12 km de
viaducs et sauvegarderait 4 hectares
supplémentaires de surfaces agricoles
une décision qui divise elle ne convainc
pas les agriculteurs et quelques élus
locaux écoutez la réaction et du maire
de magny les hameaux interrogé par
justine braz et la mise très clairement
ne règle pas la problématique et d'un
transport structurant sur rail vis-à-vis
des populations qui l'emportent ils à
vis d'une barrière écologique et
vis-à-vis de l'accès des agriculteurs ou
à travailler sur leurs terres ouais donc
de notre côté bien entendu en continuant
de demander une mise en souterrain
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'au fur et à
mesure des années la société du grand
paris continue de faire des économies
sur le dos des populations rurales ce
qu'on n'accepte pas